bom dia você começar dizendo para vocês
que alguns dias são capazes
a história por exemplo no dia 11 de
setembro
nesse dia uma série de terríveis eventos
mudaram para sempre a história do mundo
talvez seja uma coincidência mas também
no dia 11 de setembro nasceu minha filha
clara e nesse dia uma série de terríveis
eventos a deixaram com paralisia
cerebral
essa minha família e sua esposa linense
nossa filha clara e devido ao erro
médico é que causou na minha filha ela
não anda e não fala desde o momento em
que eu fiquei sabendo do que aconteceu
com a minha filha empoderar pessoas com
deficiência se tornou uma paixão para
mim e nós começamos a trabalhar para
mudar a vida não apenas a minha filha
mas a vida de milhares e milhões de
pessoas com deficiência no brasil e fora
dele
imaginem qual pior cárcere
seria talvez a solitária para milhões de
pessoas com deficiência seus corpos são
a prisão não existe pior prisão do que o
seu próprio corpo
assim como minha filha muitas pessoas
têm consciência são inteligentes mas
estão aprisionadas em corpos que não
obedecem seus comandos como é que essas
pessoas se comunicam hoje em dia
normalmente eles se comunicam através de
cartões era assim que eu me comunico a
minha filha ela quisesse uma maçã por
exemplo tinha que fazer um cartão é com
o desenho de uma maçã daquela tendência
apontada alguma forma isso é muito
complicado e foi quando a gente decidiu
criar o vox é um software uma plataforma
que permite que pessoas com deficiência
se comuniquem e também aprendam a 1 pela
primeira vez na história foram usados
inteligência artificial e consciência
contextual para criar algoritmos
inteligentes feitos especialmente para
eles
pessoas com deficiência têm algoritmos
inteligentes para deficiência motora
cognitiva e visual
não importa o nível de deficiência
motora cognitiva o visual
o lifan que se ajusta a cada um a cada
um desses tipos de deficiência
vou dar um exemplo para vocês
infelizmente não dá tempo de a gente
mostrar todos os organismos que o vox
tem mais um dos exemplos que eu posso
comentar
é com relação por exemplo ao toque as
pessoas com deficiência não tocou no
tablet como a gente toca elas batem a
mão sobre a tela do tablet arrastão a
mãe dão toques indevidos tocam não
consegue mirella também se onde querem
tocar isso é um problema muito grave e
nós queremos um dos algoritmos do vox é
um organismo que se chama entre tati que
se uma pessoa que não têm deficiência
toca na tela do tablet
o evoque sabe que essa pessoa não tem
deficiência e não faz nada
agora se uma pessoa com deficiência
toque na tela do tablet no vox calcula
quantos deles estão tocando na tela por
quanto tempo essa pessoa tá achando a
mão se não tá sendo a mão
qual a probabilidade de clicar em
determinado em 3 de acordo com o local
com e corrigir o toque perfeito da
pessoa com deficiência
uma das coisas mais interessantes também
no box é que é possível criar perfis
eu também sou diretor de uma grande
clínica de fisioterapia e nós temos um
voto com milhares de pessoas com
deficiência e nós podemos transformar é
esse conhecimento e se num raio máximo
de pessoas com deficiência em algoritmos
então vai ter sido muito usado por
exemplo escolas e aí você tem perfis por
exemplo autismo de alto funcionamento
claro perder a deficiência visual
paralisia cerebral
então imaginem que uma professora por
exemplo que acabou de ser uma pessoa com
deficiência que têm autismo selecionar o
time não levou ex-votos ajustar para as
características visuais cognitivas e
motoras alguém que tem autismo
ela recebe um outro aluno que tem
paralisia cerebral e ele escolhe
paralise paralisia cerebral
o livro se ajustar para as
características visuais e cognitivos ou
motores de alguém que tem paralisia
cerebral que são é característica de
totalmente diferente de autismo por
exemplo não há limites de deficiências
que os golpes podem atender
é possível que a infinity perfis
diagnóstico não define tipos de
deficiência
as pessoas com deficiência através dele
volks além de falar ela consegue fazer
muito mais
elas conseguem por exemplo tocar
instrumentos em aulas de música da
escola elas conseguem aprender a ler e
escrever
consegue ouvir músicas e assistir vídeos
usar em terapias aprenderem conceitos
complexos como matemática ela pare e
pense por um momento
até pouco tempo atrás essas pessoas não
conseguiam nem mesmo se comunicar
imaginem o impacto na vida diária no
cotidiano dessas pessoas que agora
consegue fazer muito mais
quantas pessoas precisam do wocs o
brasil tem 150 milhões de pessoas com
deficiência em 50 milhões de pessoas com
deficiência 15 milhões
tá certo que é mais ou menos o
equivalente à população de nova york e
londres são pessoas que aqui no brasil
necessitando vox são pessoas com
paralisia cerebral ou seqüelas de
derrame de credores lateral amiotrófica
autismo e diversas outras doenças e
deficiências que impedem o processo se
fala agora imaginem o mundo inteiro
de acordo com a organização mundial de
saúde existem cerca de 1 bilhão de
pessoas com deficiência em todo o
planeta
eles são a maior minoria do mundo
nós sabemos disso e por isso que nós
queremos um livro que irá falar 25 mil
idiomas e nós já estamos atendendo cerca
de 10 mil pessoas com deficiência em
todo o brasil as pessoas sempre me
perguntam é o que foi que eu conversei
com a minha filha já conversamos muito
através dele volks embora ela não
consiga falar normalmente e as pessoas
sempre perguntam o que foi que ela me
falou que mais o emocionou foi porque
estão vendo uma foto bem recente dela e
foi a falta de um documento
eu falei pra ela clarice um documento
com essa ponte fica séria essa foi a
forma mais séria que eu consegui tirar
dela mas enfim já assistiu a todos os
filmes da disney todos e através do vox
eu perguntei para ela qual a princesa da
disney que ela é que afinal de contas é
uma fantasia de toda menina precisa da
decisão acho que ela falou que ela é que
me ajuda
isso aqui é tímido quem falou el hatillo
10 muito bem ela disse que ela é que
quem já se o filme daniel é muito bom
já assistimos 200 vezes ontem mas enfim
o que mais me emocionou foi porque ela
disse que ela era eu vou passar agora um
filme que mostra um pouquinho porque ela
disse que ela ia num jardim
a senhorita também desculpas e se com o
batalhão assustou ele aí não vencido
você parece muito familiar pra mim já
nos vimos
já nos vivos
eu sabia é você a quem um ano procurando
como se chama o que houve
o que é isso
não pode falar
ah tá então não é que eu pensei incrível
né
ela falou pra mim que ela é da união o
que quer assistir o filme sabe que na
maior parte do filme área não só lá só
que lá perto do final do filme acontece
uma mágica e aí eu volto a falar só que
infelizmente a nossa vida não é um filme
de walt disney
mas isso não quer dizer que nós não
podemos fazer certas mágicas e nós
estamos felizes de termos criado algo
mágico que está dando voz não apenas a
minha filha mas também há milhares de
pessoas com deficiência em todo o brasil
e fora dele
e aí pessoal quando a gente sabe o que
acontece na cabeça dos nossos filhos
respondem realizações e levei ela pra
disney
ela foi conhecer ariel vestido de léo
então olha a cara dela estava
acreditando que ela finalmente está
vendo a princesa que ela tanto queria
ser
depois falou pra mim que está realizando
um sonho é finalmente conhecendo ali o
bom trabalho que nós estamos fazendo um
trabalho real inclusão social
nós já viajamos só dentro do brasil
mais de 400 mil quilômetros está certo
em todos os estados serão suficientes
para dar mais de dez voltas ao redor do
planeta terra
estive diversas vezes aqui no rio grande
do sul em várias cidades
aqui no estado também levando tecnologia
e inclusão social
nosso trabalho também foi reconhecida
diversas vezes em dezembro de 2014
estive em washington onde nós recebemos
um prêmio do banco interamericano de
desenvolvimento a inovação tecnológica
com maior impacto 2014
além disso agora em fevereiro nós
tivemos em abu dhabi
recebemos o prêmio da onu como o melhor
aplicativo de inclusão social do mundo
nós concorremos com milhares de
aplicativos em 178 países
ficamos muito felizes de fazer é trazer
essa premiação aqui para o brasil nós
temos também grandes parceiros como esse
por exemplo e acabamos de fechar também
um com a joint venture
com o consórcio de empresas é desligado
e sou milhares de votos já traduzido
localizado pra falar bem daqui a duas
semanas o retorno para essa discussão
dentro novamente para uma última reunião
técnica implantação é noite médio e no
norte da áfrica
o google ficou sabendo da nossa história
e mandou uma equipe para afirmar nossa
história pra apresentar no evento
mundial que o chamado google o que eu
queria mostrar pra vocês como foi tudo
isso em um vídeo que vai passar agora a
dia e 300 é igual a última chicane
acho que o pessoal vai mal a 57 em
dinheiro chegou a cair e se mandar o boa
esporte chique decidido se o santos tem
uma série rural inundou x é bom demais
ora mostrarem de caminho que é isso aí
na frente do santo amaro velho é isso aí
frente do box e de software de atender
15 com esse verde saber neste caminho
que entende o que no início
lembrava o ambiente depois diz a petição
de planície e voltas na production em
especial e disse a troca de calor
o sudão do sul e são paulo os dois
trechos quiséssemos mau tempo
os dois estiveram o jovem se sente o
impacto anual próximo de sair da classe
snipe jones idéia
isso foi transmitido ao vivo para o
mundo inteiro e eu tô feliz informar a
vocês que depois disso nós começamos uma
parceria com o google
estamos trabalhando em novos algoritmos
incríveis que vai mudar para sempre a
vida de milhões de pessoas com
deficiência em todo mundo
e por que o google chamou o pt lá eles
querem destacar negócios que estão tendo
substancial impacto ao redor do mundo é
você dizer pra vocês pessoal que o vox é
real não é uma ideia não é um protótipo
e já está mudando a vida de milhares de
pessoas com deficiência
eu gostaria muito de contar a história
de cada um deles
cada um desses milhares de pessoas mas
infelizmente não é possível então eu
queria mostrar para vocês a história de
três pessoas com deficiência bem
diferentes e como hawks está libertando
essas pessoas
o último vídeo x de estói depois a blush
leve toque bem chique benhê
andando aqui tudo ande melfi que no show
de natal a imago eu tenho um bebê levado
inicialmente o workshop está com o time
of my life
eu não encontrei isso a pressão do time
ontem frei nelson é bom também que matou
o músico gaúcho ainda não
foi incrível você permitir que uma
menina que tem oito anos de idade que
não consegue pegar um papel e um lápis
para se alfabetizar escrever uma
história que foi publicada em um livro
que a minha filha no caso não é permitir
que é uma pessoa teve câncer de boca que
perdeu todos os dentes a língua ea
mandíbula isso não nasce novamente essa
pessoa possa se comunicar e até de seu
cliente por telefone através do vox
disse também que um homem que os livros
com os pés uma vida limitada hoje em dia
posso ir pra balada disse que toma
cerveja é dizer que é pular de
paraquedas e pular de paraquedas
experimentar real sensação de liberdade
ea mudança por exemplo na vida desse
rapaz aí que pulou de paraquedas foi tão
grande que ele recentemente arrumar
namorada e se casou
então a mudança incrível na vida das
pessoas
eu gostaria de terminar deixando com
vocês com a frase do senador americano
daniel ebstein quando ele disse o
seguinte se todas as minhas posses
fossem tiradas de mim
com exceção de apenas uma escolha iria
manter o controle da comunicação muito
com ele e conquistaria todo o resto
muito obrigada